У 1972 році американське космічне агентство NASA відправило в космос космічний апарат - "Піонер 10".
На борту було послання, адресоване будь-яким прибульцям, в руки яких міг би потрапити космічний корабель людини.
Міжгалактичний посібник про те, "хто такі земляни".
Ідея - розповісти їм про нас. Чоловік у нас - із пенісом, а жінка... ні з чим?
Але як же ми самі в цьому помиляємося!
Пані та панове, дівчатка та хлопчики...
Вульва!
Отже, дозвольте представити вам вульву.
Це те, що видно ззовні, вхід у піхву, який веде до матки.
Це зовнішній отвір сечостатевої системи.
А це - голівка клітора і його крайня плоть.
Якщо Ви зараз подумали: "Що?! У жінок? Крайня плоть?" Про це ми вже розповідали в одній з наших серій.
А це статеві губи.
Подивімося, що і як працює.
Імовірно, ви в курсі, що вульва в нормальному стані тепла і волога. Це тому, що піхва - не тільки вхід у матку, але й вихід для...!
Є три типи вагінальних виділень. Перший - це рідкий секрет.
Він допомагає запобігти інфекції, і кількість його може змінюватися в залежності від менструального циклу.
Другий - це змазка: вона виділяється у жінок при збудженні.
І третій - це вагінальна еякуляція. У ній містяться білки, які допомагають сперматозоїдам вижити.
Піхва здатна до самоочищення. Не потрібно митися спеціальними засобами, милом або гелем для душу. Найкраще - це просто вода.
А це статеві губи, які тримають все в чистоті та безпеці.
Статеві губи частково нагадують двостулкові двері. Спочатку великі, потім малі.
Вони захищають нас від бактерій та інших інфекцій. Великі виробляють змазку і допомагають зберігати здоровими вульву і піхву.
А малі, де багато кровоносних судин і нервових закінчень, набухають, коли жінка збуджена. Вони дуже чутливі.
Вульви інших жінок, скажемо відверто, побачиш не часто... Втім, як і власну.
Тому іноді виникає чимало дивакуватих уявлень, як повинні виглядати статеві губи.
З'явився навіть різновид спеціальних пластичних операцій...
Деякі жінки впевнені, що їм статеві губи треба зменшити, інші навпаки - хочуть їх розтягнути і зробити довшими. Якого біса?!
І те, й інше спричиняє жахливий біль в дуже важливій і вкрай чутливій частині нашого тіла.
І скорочення, і розтяжка не мають абсолютного жодного сенсу!
Просто нема такого поняття, як ідеальна вульва! Усі вони різні.
Малі губи можуть бути за розміром більшими, а великі навпаки малими.
Вони можуть бути і різного кольору, і різних форм і розмірів. Але всі при цьому неймовірні!
Оскільки вульва така чутлива, вона захищена не тільки двома парами статевих губ...
Лобкове волосся - це не просто безглузда перука для вульви.
У нього дійсно дуже важлива функція - воно захищає організм від мікробів та інфекцій, а також від натирання, наприклад, під час сексу.
Тому волосяний покрив - це дійсно додатковий рівень захисту.
Звісно, за часів, коли ще не було нижньої білизни, такий захист, як лобкове волосся, був куди важливішим, ніж сьогодні.
Нині ж навпаки, багато жінок прагнуть прибрати все волосся на цьому місці...
Гоління лобкового волосся може здатися для деяких сексуальним і привабливим.
Але під час гоління можна і поранитися, а рана може стати причиною інфекції, особливо в теплі нижньої білизни.
Отже, любі пані, придивіться ближче до своєї вульви, познайомтеся! Дзеркало вам у допомогу...
... і не забудьте подивитися відео про дівочу пліву, клітор і менструації!